a la espera de un nuevo capítulo para el
diálogo en Venezuela Bogotá está lista
para acoger la conferencia internacional
sobre Venezuela impulsada por el
presidente Gustavo Petro participan al
menos 20 países con el objetivo de
desatascar las conversaciones entre el
oficialismo y la oposición que no
participarán directamente en el
encuentro el presidente venezolano
Nicolás Maduro planteó sus expectativas
una conferencia para
Buscar el levantamiento de todas las
sanciones todas las sanciones sin
condicionamiento de ningún tipo sobre
Venezuela Además del levantamiento de
sanciones el gobierno venezolano impone
otras condiciones devolver los dineros
congelados que corresponderían a 3.200
millones de dólares protegidos en el
exterior la suspensión de la
investigación en manos de la Corte Penal
Internacional por crímenes de lesa
humanidad y finalmente la liberación del
empresario colombiano alexab el
levantamiento de sanciones fue tema
central durante la visita de Petro a la
casa blanca Washington no desestima la
posibilidad pero exige pasos concretos
para unas elecciones libres en Venezuela
el chavismo y la oposición han tenido
varios acercamientos sin éxito el más
reciente iniciado en México en agosto de
2021 y suspendido hace unos meses el
líder opositor Juan guaidó estuvo en
Colombia a pesar de la prohibición de
salir de Venezuela que le impuso el
tribunal supremo
sin embargo la cancillería colombiana
informó que no está invitado a la
conferencia
espero que la Cumbre pueda garantizar
que el régimen de maduro regrese a la
mesa de negociaciones en México y se
acuerda un cronograma creíble para unas
elecciones libres y justas como solución
al conflicto Gustavo Petro también ha
insistido en cambiar la carta
democrática de la oea para reintegrar a
Venezuela otro tema a discutir en la